let's go next to the caller who is
calling in from the a25 for area code
who's calling today from two five four
hey David it's Matt hey Matt what's up
oh nothing much
two questions and they're pretty short
number one is um how do you do this
every day I take weekends totally off
that's how well Mike what the reason I
ask is K for example yesterday what
happened yesterday in the news we had
two big things we had to just we had the
Supreme Court saying that trumps taxes
could be without for the time being and
then you had before that the courts say
that McCain had to testify right so you
get you get one good thing and then
minutes later you get hammered with
something that you know makes it seem
like everything is political and justice
doesn't exist anymore and so I'm just
wondering what your thoughts are on that
issue well I would actually say it's
sadly worse than you then you're even
pointing out because even the good thing
that McGann has to testify he has to
testify but even if he does he can
assert executive privilege to every
question that's asked so it's like even
hidden in the good result is the reality
that we'll probably never get anything
substantive out of him and the theme is
that power tends to win because we have
two justice systems into financial
systems etc so I wish I could even agree
that it was one good thing and one bad
thing and it was one bad thing and one
thin leave ailing which is actually
pretty neutral or not not so good so
it's actually sadly even worse than
you're suggesting well I agree with you
on that but at the same time you can't
claim executive privilege to cover up a
crime so from again has just testifying
to exactly what he said the molar and
the mole report then I would say that
that would be a good day for the nation
to seem again in front of the diet's
there it would well the only thing that
that my belief is that he would be
testifying only under the umbrella of
the Ukraine impeachment hearings so I
don't know that the molar stuff would
necessarily even be part of it but that
remains to be seen
and then my second question is what are
your thoughts on this whole Lum
Gallagher Navy SEAL I don't think Trump
quite knows exactly what he's doing
no no in this area um with with our
military it's it's a dangerous game he's
playing and he's he's in inserting and I
understand he's the commander in chief
sure but he's got no real I mean he's a
businessman I get that and he was a real
estate business man but it was it was a
family owned business it wasn't a big
corporation so when you have some like
the military years in the active service
I'm still in the reserves slash IRR
deployed five times for Iraq one in
Afghanistan but it's just one of those
things where where he's dividing the the
one thing that shouldn't be divided like
I was watching Gallagher on Fox News I'm
not sure when he went on but he was
saying that it's all about ego and that
you know the people above him are just
out to get him and this that and the
other and he's saying that his buddies
and the military support him and right I
guess - you let me ask you that because
my view has been that what Donald Trump
is doing by pardoning war criminals is
very dangerous because it could be seen
as a signal to people in active duty
that even if you do something which your
superiors aren't telling you is okay to
do and which the law says isn't OK to do
that you're being sort of signaled by
the president that maybe it is sort of
okay and that you might end up with a
pardon that's my concern as someone
you're better positioned to answer this
than I am as someone who actually served
like you said five tours overseas it is
that the way that this decision could be
interpreted that maybe you can get away
with more than you're actually told you
can get away with it's it's a bit sad
Ange
thing to undertake I'll put it that way
it's one of those things where you know
when you join the military when you go
overseas you receive all kinds of
briefings from you know the Jag officers
this any other but Geneva Convention
rules of engagement your roee you're
also engaged in all that stuff and
everything is laid out pretty much in
black and white so it's just one of
those things where if you know Gallagher
went over there and he did what he did
I'm not saying they did anything you
know
significant he you know killed a bad guy
then he took a picture with you know in
front of it yep is that necessarily you
know all that bad
no but it is against you know our rules
so it's one of those things in our wall
so it's one of those things where if you
did the crime guess what you know right
you got a do you sign the contract you
said okay to the to the laws that
governs you know what you were doing
over there so I don't have any you know
no real sympathy he chose to do what he
did his brothers in arms kind of went
against what he did and I think he got
what he deserved
his life wasn't over young yeah he
wasn't anything so I don't know I don't
know I'm just I'm worried that that that
Trump is dividing the the services and
the people who you know serve the
country faithfully and who do it by the
law they see this and I'm worried that
they're gonna look at this and be like
well what do we do now right you know
the how how are you going to how you're
going to punish somebody in your ranks
for you know going outside of the bounds
the yeah you got Trump in the White
House saying well you know this guy did
it and he's because I mean I can't tell
you because I was in during the search
and you know I enlisted in 2002 I'm
after 9/11 and I'm still in not active
but I'm and it's just one of those
things where I guess I'm just worried I
sure I totally share the concern with
you and I really appreciate you calling
in and sharing your perspective I hope
to hear from you again thank you so much
for the call really appreciate it